Florian let me ask you about this this
uh obviously you did the father uh with
Anthony Hopkins who also won a
well-deserved Oscar was nominated for
best picture and an extraordinary movie
this is the second and actually the uh
like the father based on a play and you
also have a third that you've got in
this Trilogy on mental health and and
those issues here so how did it all come
about how did you decide to do this on
this subject matter in different ways in
these films
laughs it's a difficult question but uh
but it's the first so I jump
um now it's true that the sun is also
the adaptation of one of my place that I
wrote five years ago and when I did the
father I already knew that I would I
would do the sun because it was like a
story that was so important for me to
tell and to share and I thought it was a
story important to be told and
um what happened is that we did the the
play in France on stage in Paris because
I'm French
you can hear and
and when I wrote the play I guess in the
first place it was about sharing
um it was coming from a personal place
not to tell my own story but it was
exploring things that I was familiar
with
and what I realized through the stage
experience is that so many people are
connected to this issue and it was quite
extraordinary after every performance to
feel that people were waiting for us to
share their own story to tell their own
story and it was a way I mean I I really
felt that they were
um aware of what I was trying to tell
um and I realized that so many people
could have an experience of that you
know as a parent to be in a position
when you do not know what to do anymore
or to experience uh powerlessness to
feel important to discover that love
sometimes is not enough and I know that
there are so many people in pain and
there are so much ignorance and so much
shame and guilt and um and denial around
these topics that I really wanted to
open a conversation and my way to do it
was to make that film yeah without
question two you also had like I
mentioned we have a professional here
available if anybody wants to talk to
them and you had that on the set as well
at all times for the cast and the crew
because this is very very heavy subject
matter too to be dealing with day in and
day out for a crew making a movie as
well
yeah it's true our producers were
inspired enough to organize uh on set
the possibility for everyone the crew
the cast everyone to have a room to to
talk and to share emotions that could
overwhelm us but on the other hand we
were like a small group of people on set
it was in the middle of kovid so it was
like a very intimate atmosphere
atmosphere and it was like um
somehow an intense Spirit joyful moment
and journey Laura what was it like she
is such a heartbreaking character in and
of herself you know she's sort of when
we meet her you can see she's at her
Wit's End and she brings him there what
was it like playing Kate uh you know
who's got her own background and
problems from that marriage and trying
to bring up this son and and having her
own problems
well if I may I would just start by
saying you know um and I know I I speak
for all of us the cast
um what a blessing it is to work with
Florian Zeller
um as you can even hear from the way he
describes the Journey of of making a
film and working with actors so
um having seen the father and then
reading the play and then of course This
Magnificent screenplay
of the sun I just
I felt such immense gratitude uh to play
the role and and be part of writing and
storytelling like this
um
but also we were not only in the middle
of a global pandemic but the epidemic as
we were all reading Figures On The Rise
particularly not only mental health in
general but particularly amongst
adolescents and young adults
and as a mother and a human to feel like
I could put all the fear alonging
confusion
um
and misunderstanding about it all into
story and connecting with all of you and
others that that was just incredible
and then yes and then the role which I
um you know was moved to tears just
reading it I told Florian when we met
the first time over Zoom
um
that just the restaurant scene on the
page was just one of the most beautiful
pieces of writing I'd I'd ever read and
and
um for two actors to get to share an
entire life story in a scene
um and what it captured was so amazing
not to mention the whole movie and I
will give you the other actor here
Vanessa here you are you're not a mother
yet is that right no well you were in
this movie
and so realistically and working with a
newborn baby and the idea of that you're
in this marriage and you're sort of
thrust into
this family situation so she has her
hands full too uh what was that like in
preparing to play that kind of a role
yeah no I'm I'm uh I'm not a mother I
learned that the baby was a far better
act than I was much more relaxed
but no it was it was amazing to work I
hadn't worked with the you know
um I mean the babies were we work with
twins didn't we they were how old really
young
four four five months four months yeah I
just I because I had my mother and I
felt oh I just want to make sure that I
really understand what the experience of
new motherhood is and it was a privilege
to get to know you know just even a
little bit about it so I spent as much
time as I could with babies in the
pandemic I drove a few hours outside
London to be with them and their lovely
mom who taught me everything about
nappies and
you know just just it was the whole
experience of having a newborn which is
you know as a woman to
to do that but then do it on your own as
well as
try and support your the person that
you've done that with to go through
their own Journey how many families must
be trying to navigate the the pressures
of
um
your own experience and your own need to
your sense of self and identity
alongside somebody else and co-create a
new family that's a blended family and
how to do that without navigating
dysfunction and the ways you fall down
when doing that and things you get wrong
and it was for me it was really
interesting inhabiting a person who
quite literally couldn't say how she
felt that was so hard to do
um and try and be the best that you
could in the dynamic while feeling like
um
her experience wasn't
um it couldn't be in this space because
there was something so much more
difficult going on but that was a really
interesting I think we're all in those
circumstances and different points in
life where you have to suppress
your experience because you know and
whether that's the right thing to do or
not who knows and it was a yeah a really
fascinating exploration of that for me
but difficult because like I said before
and I wanted to scream sometimes didn't
I was like guys what are we all doing
but um that was uh yeah it made me very
much appreciate the the the how
difficult it is to be a new mother and
potentially do it on your own and how
isolating that might feel it's amazing
Joe can you tell me from the producer's
point of view here how important to get
all the real authenticity here to have
the professionals available the research
everything that goes into making this
movie and making it cinematic and and
fulfilling Florian's Vision as well I
mean massively important when you're
making a movie that deals with mental
health just making sure that the crew
knew what kind of film they were making
we wanted to have once really Ops in but
because of the father I think everyone
was
desperate to work alongside of this
incredible filmmaking talent and these
incredible actors
um Laura was just saying about that line
I'm basically sort of frightened of my
son I think speaks to the truth that
Florian conveys in his writing which is
is the stuff we kind of
tell each other in bed at night you know
they're difficult things to confront and
I love that we got to take this
opportunity to be
um in a story that speaks to so many of
our feelings but they're just kind of
difficult to say out loud and I think
um it is it is tough but one of the
things that I learned as part of the
training that I did and certainly we
offered up to all of the crew and the
cast
um
was mental health support So we had a
whole service we saw this mind and we're
working with nami now just to make sure
that we lead people through the release
um uh knowing that everyone was really
supported but
um yeah we we often don't talk about the
fact that um with suicide you sort of
have to deal with it head-on
one of the things that
um they you know advise is if you feel
like someone is feeling suicidal you
have to talk and I think this film opens
that conversation
yeah Ben I haven't forgotten you the
extraordinary cinematography here
you may not notice what he's doing in in
coordination with Florian here but can
you talk about your approach to this the
cameras that you use for certain scenes
and the way you did it for other scenes
in relation to what the characters are
feeling
um well this film encapsulates
everything I love about Cinema that we
can tell a story that needs telling and
it's it's in a sense similar to the
previous film that I worked on with uh
flying the father and
I I just love making films
that can touch people and and make them
think and however I can do that there's
lots of techniques
that I can use to help tell that story
and most of them are subtle and I I need
that subtlety to to help the story
um I mean Florian I just really go
through
the film word by word emotion about
emotion in great detail before we get
anywhere near the set because you just
because you you because we have to but
we also enjoy it
um I must also say I'm the luckiest
person in this panel because uh because
I operate the camera as well so I get to
see I have a front row seat to
Great Performances which are which is
helping tell the story so I get to see
that and I get to see it up close and um
even though I don't quite get as many
rehearsals as I possibly would like
sometimes
um I actually it's a thrill to see that
and and and and it really is my job to
not get in the way of that story that
story needs to be told it's not about
the lighting and it's not about me I
just have to capture it however hard is
and it was a tough shoot you know it's
it's quite a small intimate film but it
was pretty tough but I knew every minute
that I turned up every single day that I
was doing something important well
amazing job from everybody uh thank you
so much for coming out here tonight
sharing the story behind the story of
the Sun and best of luck with the film
as it goes out into the world thank you
very much thank you so much for coming
and thank you Peter being the best
[Applause]